Hace unos días se hizo muy viral este
tweet en el cual una persona utilizando
la Inteligencia artificial puso la voz
de Quevedo en un montón de canciones muy
famosas
en Este vídeo lo que voy a hacer va a
ser crear varias canciones de Quevedo
como las que hemos visto utilizando la
Inteligencia artificial e incluso voy a
crear una canción totalmente nueva que
no existe creada por la propia
Inteligencia artificial el objetivo es
ver cuántas visitas consigo generar en
tan solo una semana y por aquí ya tengo
todas las canciones que hemos creado en
este documento de Google Drive podemos
ver todas las canciones lo que hemos
hecho ha sido preparar tanto la canción
Como una portada y la hemos intentado
hacer así divertida Como por ejemplo
Pues esta de David Bisbal Y eso aquí
tenemos 17 canciones pero estamos
preparando dos canciones adicionales y
lo único que voy a hacer va a ser
simplemente subir todos los días 5
canciones y cinco shorts ya estamos al
último día de este reto lo primero que
tenemos por aquí es el tiktok la verdad
que no ha sido ninguna locura pero sí
que hemos conseguido pues bastantes
visitas pero realmente interesante es
YouTube y es que si venimos al Canal
tenemos 31 suscriptores tenemos 4.700
visitas 47,5 horas de visualización Y el
gráfico pues es bastante interesante si
os fijáis Así que la verdad es que estoy
bastante contento y siento que si
siguiese subiendo más vídeos el canal
Pues empezaría a crecer